finally it wasn't via video conference
but in writing by way of a 12-page
document that edward snowden responded
to meps this week
they had invited the u.s computer
specialist to testify on relations
between nsa and eu secret services
snowden preferred respond in writing
then via video conference due to safety
concerns his message came from russia
where he's been seeking refuge since his
requests for asylum were rejected
snowden spoke frankly not only on the
role of nsa but also on that of the
european secret services
the result is a european bazaar
ultimately eu national government spy
services are independently hawking
domestic access to nsa without knowing
how this is enabling the greater
patchwork of mass surveillance against
ordinary citizens as a whole on march
the 12th meps will vote on the inquiry
report on the repercussions of the nsa
surveillance what we did in the inquiry
is to to try and build a sort of digital
uh bill of rights to go beyond just
examining his allegations but to then
build a sort of digital bill of rights
or digital habeas corpus a set of
demands for the future for citizens
fighting biopiracy is the target of the
nagoya protocol an international
agreement meps have finally ratified in
the name of the eu despite intense
lobbying from seed manufacturers
currently the cosmetic pharmaceutical
and seed industries compete for and
utilize natural resources
at times these resources and the
ancestral heritage of local populations
who alone hold the secret to their
existence
the nagoya protocol will facilitate a
fairer sharing the benefits arising out
of these resources but it doesn't stop
there
important
there are more than 219 million vehicles
on the roads in europe
cars buses and trucks travel freely
across a 3.4 million kilometers of
european roads to reinforce road safety
and safeguard the environment neps have
adopted a report harmonising
roadworthiness tests for vehicles the
aim lay down minimum standards across eu
countries